SEE YOU TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO HANNITY
TONIGHT.
WE ARE AT THE END OF A VERY BUSY
DAY IN THE WASHINGTON SWAMP.
IN THE SENATE, DEMOCRATS JUST
CONFIRMED A FAR LEFT DEMOCRATIC
ACTIVIST TO THE SUPREME COURT
WITH THE HELP OF OF COURSE MITT
ROMNEY, LISA MURKOWSKI, THE
USUAL.
IN THE HOUSE, COVID-19 POSITIVE
NANCY PELOSI, WE DO WISH HER THE
BEST, HAS BEEN SPREADING THE
VIRUS APPARENTLY TO EVERYONE IN
SIGHT.
LOOK AT THIS PICTURE.
THAT'S FROM YESTERDAY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
YET WE HAVE BIDEN'S DISHONEST
PRESS SECRETARY CIRCLING BACK
AND REPORTEDLY HAS A BRAND NEW
WELL PAID FOR GIG AT MSNBC.
MOST OF THEIR HOSTS LIE.
THAT'S SET TO BEGIN IN A FEW
WEEKS.
SHE'S STILL WORKING AS PRESS
SECRETARY.
BY THE WAY, NBC NEWS SHOWING
THEIR HIGH ETHICAL STANDARDS
ONCE AGAIN.
WE'LL GET INTO THAT IN A MINUTE.
FIRST MORE BREAKING NEWS ON JOE
BIDEN'S BIG LIE.
IN 2020, BIDEN REPEATEDLY SWORE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THAT HE
NEVER ONE TIME EVER COMMUNICATED
WITH HIS SON OR BROTHER ABOUT
THEIR FOREIGN BUSINESS AFFAIRS
OR DEALINGS.
JOE BIDEN WAS LYING.
NOT ONLY DID BIDEN DISCUSS THESE
DEALS, HE WAS AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT.
IN FACT, "NEW YORK POST" JUST
LISTED A DOZEN TIMES THAT JOE
BIDEN PLAYED A ROLE IN ZERO
EXPERIENCE HUNTER BIDEN'S
INTERNATIONAL MONEY MAKING
VENTURES.
FIRST IS JOE'S LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION.
WE DETAILED THIS LAST NIGHT.
NOT ONLY DID HE WRITE A LETTER
OF RECOMMENDATION FOR HUNTER'S
CHINESE BUSINESS PARTNER.
HE ALSO SENT A LETTER TO THE
HEAD OF BROWN UNIVERSITY.
BIDEN WROTE A SECOND LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATION OF HUNTER'S OTHER
FRIEND'S CHILD.
THIS TIME TO GEORGETOWN.
NEITHER GOT IN.
SO MUCH FOR THE IMPACT OF A
BIDEN RECOMMEND EIGHT LETTER.
NOW HUNTER ALSO ACKNOWLEDGED IN
2019 IN THE NEW YORKER THAT HE
AND HIS DAD ONCE DISCUSSED
HUNTER'S JOB ON THE BOARD OF
BARIFA HOLDS.
SO WHO'S TELLING THE TRUTH?
AS VICE PRESIDENT JOE WAS ALSO
INTRODUCED TO ONE OF HUNTER'S
BUSINESS PARTNERS DURING THEIR
SIX DAY TRIP TOGETHER THROUGH
ASIA ON AIR FORCE TWO.
THAT'S WHEN HE MET WITH
PRESIDENT XI.
MEANWHILE, IN TEXT MESSAGES
RETRIEVED FROM ZERO EXPERIENCED
HUNTER'S LAP TOP FROM HELL,
HUNTER BIDEN COMPLAINED THAT HE
HAD TO FORK OVER HALF OF HIS
EARNINGS TO, QUOTE, POPS.
LET'S NOT FORGET ABOUT THIS
PICTURE OF THE PAIR WITH
HUNTER'S FAVORITE OLIGARCH WHO
SAID HIS COMPANY 100 GRAND FOR A
BRAND NEW SPORTS CAR.
HERE'S A PICTURE WITH HUNTER
BIDEN'S MEXICAN BUSINESS
PARTNERS.
IN AN E-MAIL HUNTER COMPLAINED
TO ONE MEXICAN ASSOCIATE HE
HADN'T RECEIVED ANYTHING TO
VALUE EXCEPT BRINGING EVERY
SINGLE PERSON YOU HAVE ASKED ME
TO BRING TO THE BLEEPING WHITE
HOUSE AND THE VICE PRESIDENT'S
HOUSE AND THE INAUGURATION.
HERE ARE JOE AND HUNTER GOLFING
WITH HUNTER BIDEN'S MAIN
BUSINESS PARTNER WHO ALSO SERVED
ON THE BOARD OF BARISMA
HOLDINGS.
ARCHER HAS BEEN CONVICTED OF
FRAUD.
HE WILL SOON BE REPORTING TO
PRISON.
JOE BIDEN ALSO MET WITH HUNTER'S
OTHER BUSINESS PARTNER TONY
BOBALINSKY WHO IDENTIFIED JOE
BIDEN AS THE BIG GUY AS IT
APPEARS ON HUNTER'S LAP TOP AND
IS SET TO RECEIVE A 10% PAYOUT
IN HUNTER'S DEALINGS WITH A
CHINESE ENERGY COMPANY.
E-MAILS FROM HUNTER BIDEN'S LAP
TOP IN 2017 ALSO REVEAL HUNTER
WAS GETTING FEES MADE TO AN
OFFICE FOR JOE BIDEN, JAMES
BIDEN AND A CHINESE EXECUTIVE.
HUNTER IS UNDER A FEDERAL
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION FOR
INTERNATIONAL MONEY LAUNDERING
AND TAX EVASION.
THE BIDEN SYNDICATE MAY SOON BE
INDICTED.
A GRAND JURY WANTS MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHO THIS BIG
GUY IS AND ABOUT THE BIG GUY'S
10% PAYOUT.
OF COURSE, OTHER MONIES
RECEIVED.
NOW, IF YOU JUST IMAGINE FOR A
SECOND IF THIS WERE PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND ONE OF HIS KIDS.
MEDIA HIS TIERIA WOULD BE UNLIKE
ANYTHING WE HAVE EVER SEEN.
DURING THE 2020 ELECTION, THE
MEDIA MOB, THEY REFUSED TO
REPORT ON ANY OF THIS MATERIAL.
IN FACT, THEY CALLED THE LAP TOP
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
REMEMBER THIS LAP TOP CAME OUT
TWO WEEKS BEFORE THE ELECTION
AND, REMEMBER BIG TECH, TWITTER,
FACE BOOK, THEY ABSOLUTELY
BANNED ANYBODY FROM EVEN SHARING
THE INFORMATION TO DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES.
YOU MAY REMEMBER.
>> FEDERAL AUTHORITIES ARE
INVESTIGATING WHETHER RECENTLY
PUBLISHED E-MAILS THAT PURPORT
TO DETAIL THE BUSINESS DEALS OF
JOE BIDEN'S SON ARE TIED TO AN
ON GOING RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
EFFORT.
>> RECENTLY PUBLISHED E-MAILS
THAT PURPORT DETAILS OF BUSINESS
DEALING OF JOE BIDEN'S SON ARE
PART OF AN ON GOING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN.
>> HUNTER BIDEN'S LAP TOP THAT
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS HAVE
WARNED IS LIKELY RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> TO ME, THIS IS CLASSIC
TEXTBOOK SOVIET RUSSIAN CRAFTED
WORK.
>> CNN REPORTED FRIDAY U.S.
AUTHORITIES ARE SEEKING IF THOSE
E-MAILS ARE CONNECTED TO AN ON
GOING RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
CAMPAIGN.
>> Sean: NOW THAT THE ELECTION
IS IN THE REAR VIEW MIRROR THE
LAP TOP IS BEING VALIDATED BY
THE MULTIPLE OUTLETS.
WHY DID THAT HAPPEN AT THIS
TIME?
COULD IT BE THEY KNEW THE GRAND
JURY WAS ASKING REALLY IMPORTANT
SERIOUS SIGNIFICANT QUESTIONS
AND THAT THEY WOULD BE EXPOSED
AS THE FRAUDS THEY ARE?
I DON'T KNOW.
CALL ME CYNICAL.
DON'T EXPECT THEM TO CORRECT THE
RECORD IN ANY WAY.
DON'T EXPECT AN APOLOGY.
THAT WON'T HAPPEN.
HAS ANYONE CORRECTED THE RECORD
ON ALL THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
LIES?
HAVE THEY CORRECTED THE SLANDER
AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AND THEIR
FAMILY?
THEY KNOW THEY BURIED THE
SCANDAL.
THEY KNOW THEY WANTED TO HELP
GET JOE BIDEN ELECTED.
THEY'RE NOT SORRY ABOUT IT AND
THEY'RE NOT GONNA ACT SORRY
ABOUT IT.
REMEMBER THE DECENT HYSTERIA
OVER THE TRUMP PHONE LOGS.
>> TONIGHT 7 HOURS AND 37
MINUTES MISSING LOGS FROM
JANUARY 6TH SHOW THAT GAP IN THE
FORMER PRESIDENT'S PHONE
RECORDS.
WAS THERE A BURNER PHONE?
>> SEVEN HOURS?
18 MINUTES OF ERASED TAPES OVER
WATERGATE LOOKS LIKE A GAME OF
PATTY CAKE.
>> THAT IS THE ENTIRE WINDOW.
>> WE NEED TO KNOW WHO HE SPOKE
TO AND WHAT THEY TALKED ABOUT
AND WHY WANTED TO HIDE IT.
>> THIS ASTONISHING SEVEN HOUR
AND 37 MINUTE GAP YOU AND I GO
BACK TO 1970S AND WATERGATE.
IT WAS ONLY AN 18 AND A HALF
MINUTE GAP.
>> Sean: THEY'RE SO EXCITED,
THEY'RE GIDDY WITH EXCITEMENT.
WE FINALLY GOT HIM.
THE STORY WAS TOTALLY BOGUS.
NONE OF THAT SPECULATION ON THE
FAKE NEWS NETWORKS TURNED OUT TO
BE TRUE.
BUT YET AGAIN, NONE OF THESE
MEDIA HACKS EVER APOLOGIZE OR
CORRECT THE RECORD.
THEY JUST MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
GROUP OF LIES.
THAT'S WHY I HAVE BEEN SAYING
SINCE 2007, RIGHT HERE ON THIS
PROGRAM, JOURNALISM IN AMERICA
IS DEAD, DONE, GONE AND BURIED.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, WE HAVE A MAJOR
MASSIVE INFORMATION CRISIS IN
THIS COUNTRY.
LOOK, I'M NOT SAYING THEY CAN'T
HAVE OPINIONS.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS THEY NEED TO
BE HONEST LIKE WE ARE ON THIS
PROGRAM.
AM I A MEMBER OF THE PRESS?
OBVIOUSLY.
I AM A TALK SHOW HOST.
I TELL YOU WHAT I DO FOR A
LIVING.
I COULD PRODUCE THOUSANDS OF
HOUR OF RADIO AND TV OF ME
PROVIDING STRAIGHT NEWS, NO
OPINION.
WE'VE DONE INVESTIGATIVE
REPORTING.
BARACK OBAMA'S RADICAL
ASSOCIATIONS.
THE TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION LIE
NARRATIVE.
WE SPENT THREE YEARS ON THAT.
I'M UP FRONT.
I'M A CONSERVATIVE.
I OFFER MY OPINION.
I TELL YOU THE CANDIDATES I LIKE
AND DON'T LIKE.
WE DO CULTURAL ISSUES.
WE DO SPORTS.
THIS SHOW IS LIKE AN ENTIRE
NEWSPAPER.
WE DO IT ALL.
THE DIFFERENCE IS, THEY CLAIM
THEY ARE OBJECTIVE AND FAIR AND
BALANCED AND THAT THEY'RE
JOURNALISTS.
THEY'RE NOT.
SAD TO TELL THEM, BUT THEY'RE
JUST TALK SHOW HOSTS WITH
OPINIONS LIKE ME, EXCEPT THEY
LIE AND CLAIM TO BE SOMETHING
THEY'RE NOT.
LISTEN TO ONE ATLANTA REPORTER
AT A DISINFORMATION CONFERENCE
WEDNESDAY.
>> DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA ACTED
INAPPROPRIATELY WHEN THEY SAID
HUNTER BIDEN'S LAP TOP WAS
DISINFORMATION.
>> MY PROBLEM WITH HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAP TOP IS TOTALLY
IRRELEVANT.
IT'S NOT WHETHER IT'S
DISINFORMATION.
I DIDN'T THINK HUNTER BIDEN'S
BUSINESS RELATIONSHIPS HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO WITH WHO SHOULD
BE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
I DON'T FIND IT INTERESTING.
THAT WOULD BE MY PROBLEM WITH
THAT AS A MAJOR NEWS STORY.
>> Sean: THIS MIGHT BE MY
FAVORITE.
MAKE BELIEVE JOURNALISTS FULL
TIME HANNITY STALKER REFERRED TO
VALID CRITICISM OF FAKE NEWS CNN
AS A VAST RIGHT WING CONSPIRACY.
NOTICE HE NEVER WILL ANSWER THE
QUESTION THAT THIS STUDENT IS
RIGHTLY ASKING ABOUT HOW
ABUSIVELY CORRUPT AND BIAS FAKE
NEWS CNN IS.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THEY TALKED ABOUT RUSSIAN
INCLUSION.
THEY PUSHED THE JESSIE SMOLLETT
RACIST HOAX, THEY DISMISS THE
HUNTER BIDEN AFFAIR AS PURE
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
WITH MAIN STREAM CORPORATE
JOURNALISTS BECOMING LITTLE MORE
THAN APOLOGISTS AND CHEERLEADERS
FOR THE REGIME, IS THERE TIME TO
FINALLY DECLARE THAT THE CANNON
OF JOURNALISTIC ETHICS IS DEAD
OR NO LONGER OPERATIVE?
CNN PUTS IN PARTICULAR SEEM TO
IMAGINICALLY ALL GO IN ONE
DIRECTION.
ARE WE EXPECTED TO BELIEVE THIS
IS ALL SOME SORT OF RANDOM
COINCIDENCE?
>> TOO BAD.
TIME FOR LUNCH.
>> 30 SECONDS.
>> I THINK MY HONEST ANSWER TO
YOU, AND I'LL TALK IN MORE
DETAIL AFTER THIS, IS THAT
YOU'RE DESCRIBING A DIFFERENT
CHANNEL THAN THE ONE I WATCH.
I UNDERSTAND THAT IS A POPULAR
RIGHT WING VIEW OF CNN.
>> Sean: THAT STUDENT WAS 1,000%
RIGHT ON EVERY ISSUE FAKE NEWS
CNN GOT WRONG.
LITTLE HUMPTY DUMPTY SAT ON A
WALL AND COULDN'T ANSWER THE
QUESTION.
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION WAS THREE
YEARS OF CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
LIES AND A HOAX.
WHAT HE SAID ABOUT JUSTICE
KAVANAUGH WAS TRUE AND HE WASN'T
A RAPIST.
CNN ENDED UP PAYING HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT NICHOLAS SAND MAN A TON
OF MONEY AFTER THEY VICIOUSLY
SMEARED HIM ON THEIR NETWORK.
THAT'S NOT A RIGHT WING
NARRATIVE.
THAT'S CALLED FACTS, SOMETHING
YOU DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS CURRENT
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY JEN
PSAKI CIRCLE BACK WILL SOON BE
ON THE PEACOCK NETWORK.
APPARENTLY SOME NBC STAFFERS AND
NEWS PEOPLE SAY THEY ARE WORRIED
SHE HAS BEEN HIRED TO DEFEND THE
NETWORK'S STERLING REPUTATION.
YOU THINK YOU HAVE A STERLING
REPUTATION?
YOU'RE LIVING IN MARS.
THIS IS THE SAME NETWORK THAT
EMPLOYS CHUCK TODD.
SAME NETWORK THAT FEATURES
RUSSIA COLLUSION TRUTHERS LIKE
RACHEL MADDOW AND EVERYBODY ELSE
ON.
I THINK JEN PSAKI WILL PROBABLY
FIT IN PERFECTLY THERE.
SHE IS A NOTORIOUS LIAR.
WE HAVE THE TAPE TO PROVE IT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU MAY HAVE NOTICED GAS
PRICES HAVE GONE UP.
I WANT TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHY.
LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
VLADAMIR PUTIN.
IT IS WIDELY KNOWN THAT THERE
WAS A BROAD RANGE OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION BACK IN 2020.
>> WHY IS THIS ADMINISTRATION
PUTTING MIGRANTS TO THE BORDER
AND FLORIDA IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT?
>> I'M NOT SURE IT'S IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
AS INDIVIDUALS COME ACROSS THE
BORDER AND THEY ARE BOTH
ASSESSED FOR WHETHER THEY HAVE
ANY SYMPTOMS.
IF THEY HAVE SYMPTOMS, THE
INTENTION IS FOR THEM TO BE
QUARANTINED.
THEY'RE NOT INTENDING TO STAY
HERE FOR A LENGTHY PERIOD OF
TIME.
>> Sean: THEY WON'T BE THERE FOR
A PERIOD OF TIME BECAUSE THEY
WILL FLY THEM TO THE STATE OF
THEIR CHOICE.
WHETHE